hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who episode 10 video
there's so much WTF to talk about so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet there is a new
round of the giveaway that starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
so here we go starting with top 5 WTF
number 5
rigsy is back from flatline and he calls
the TARDIS phone there is a tattoo that
is counting down to God knows what if
you guys didn't recognize him from
flatline last year he's back he was a
lot of fun then and his presence in this
episode like the fact that they featured
him so much made me wonder if he was
gonna be companion I think that Moffat
definitely knows who the next companion
is already it could totally be rigsy I'm
kind of hoping they pull in someone that
we'd never seen before Rick sees kind of
a MacGuffin in the episode I think the
episode was really about Clara trying to
be too clever or trying to imitate the
doctor too much that she actually
thought of herself as the doctor going
back to flatline rig Z's last episode
she pretended to be the doctor in that
episode too I mean she does it all the
time
but in that episode it was really on the
nose cuz she had the Sonic so on my
number 4 WTF Cara being reckless
is an ongoing problem as the doctor says
hanging out of the TARDIS just like Matt
Smith in the 50th anniversary that was a
nice callback to that the problem is
Clara does not have lives to burn like
the doctor does she can't be that
reckless in of the Companions that have
been altered or gotten powers in some
way usually it's through some crazy
accident of the TARDIS like they fused
with the TARDIS matrix become the bad
wolf entity where they get trapped on
the outside infused with artron energy
and you turn into Captain Jack but none
of those things have happened to Clara
she's still just a normal person even
though she was the impossible girl for a
little while they kind of dropped that
storyline to I'm assuming that this
version of car that died is Clara prime
but there's always gonna be little story
bits like that in Doctor Who that Moffat
lets trail off unless he brings it back
in a future episode like Capaldi is
pretty much coming back for series 10 so
just expect them to do the Matt Smith
thing with the cracks a really small
thing from early and Capaldi's run
becomes a really big thing late in his
run but just in case you were wondering
Moffat did say that they're gonna do a
full series 10 it's not going to be a
shortened run despite budgetary problems
but on the number three a shield ER has
her own Diagon Alley or platform and 3/4
however you want to think about it this
sanctuary for all the creatures of the
universe if they need it
she actually throws some Zygons shade in
the doctors face whenever she talks
about the truce she brokered to keep the
sanctuary safe no one harms each other
here we have a truce unlike the ones you
brokered with the Zygons outside and
once we learned that the whole murder
mystery was just a device to get the
doctor there it actually does make it
sound like her truce works way better
than the one the Zygons had so her
secret ally actually works really well
it's just that in the larger context she
has to sell the doctor out to this
mystery group to continue to keep the
Ally safe to keep the true strong but
out of my number two WTF doctor 101 and
102 car takes rig zis tattoo she kind of
makes half of a plan up like oh I am
under the protection of his shelter so
we'll put the mark on me so she won't be
able to kill me in the end because she
vowed to protect me 101 talking your
enemies into their own trap doctor 102
never tell anyone your real plan somehow
I don't think the car's real plan was to
die in place of rigsy and she really
doesn't figure it out to those last
moments when she talks it through like
oh you can only stave off death you
can't cheat it completely there's a lot
we can say about cars run in general but
just within the context of this episode
I feel like her death is permanent I
don't think that she's gonna come back I
think that's the way they wanted things
to seem at the end when the doctor
turned on his children and said that
Clara's comment about not taking revenge
was about not taking revenge on a
shielder for what happened to Clara you
will find the universe is a very small
place when I'm angry with you but
finally on my number one WTF a mystery
group bargains with the shield ER to
teleport the doctor to a secret location
that we don't know about it's a two-part
finale and based on the markings on that
teleport band I think he was teleported
somewhere in and around Gallifrey if not
to Gallifrey itself and also I think
that's why the confession dial was an
important part of that equation where
she's like they also requested your
confession dial the funny thing being
that the doctor has absolutely no idea
how it works I have heard tell that the
doctor will travel actually travel back
to Gallifrey now it's in the pocket
universe but he was able to communicate
with them when he regenerated into
Capaldi so I'm guessing that special
teleport band took him to wherever
Gallifrey is in that pocket universe
there was a lot of talk about the
quantum shade device in the episode how
you could go anywhere in time and space
in the galaxy anywhere and the device
would still find you and kill you so I
think the matically the teleport band is
like that no matter where Gallifrey is
you can use whatever logic you want it's
just designed to take the doctor back
there but because the finale is a
two-part episode and I think the sisters
of Caron are coming back he could be
somewhere else like it could have
teleported him somewhere else but at
some point in those last two episodes he
is supposed to end up on Gallifrey and
just because there's been so much fourth
doctor during Capaldi's run remember
during the fourth doctor's run he was on
Gallifrey without a companion for a
certain period of time so I think this
is gonna be something of a call back to
those Tom Baker episodes let me know in
the comments what would your favorite
part about this episode did you hate
Clara did you love Clara I will say you
know I think I liked Amy Pond a little
bit better but that's because she was
one of my earliest companions when I
first started watching the show most of
Christopher Eccleston and David Tennant
episodes I didn't watch till after
they'd already aired like I caught up
with them before Matt Smith Matt Smith's
run was the first one that I watched as
it aired on TV so usually you just you
end up liking the first companion that
you come on it's the same way with
doctors like people tend to like the
first doctor that they watched when we
get through the Christmas special though
we can rear ank the companions to see
where Clara fits I would say just my
initial reaction in terms of knew who
companions only she'd be somewhere at
least in the middle if not a little bit
better typically when I think about
companions it's not so much the
companion on their own it's like the
companion in their relationship with the
doctor and I like the dynamic that Amy
in the Matt Smith doctor had but I like
the tone of Capaldi's run better I like
the like the darker more serious tone
just to talk about some of the Easter
eggs from the episode the doctor says he
identifies 27 different species
including Sontarans Cybermen Judoon in
ode Silurians who actually just
mentioned in last week's episode and
then Clara says don't be a warrior be a
doctor so that's very clearly a
reference to the night of the doctor
when the Eighth Doctor regenerated into
the war doctor before the 50th
anniversary a couple of callbacks to the
50th anniversary in this episode which
is why thematically I think we're also
heading to Gallifrey in the finale but
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Scott Wilson please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info if you
guys haven't seen it i've been posting
jessica jones
episode videos I've posted through
episode 8 I'm basically doing like
blocks of four episodes my next video
for that will post on Monday just
because Sunday has Walking Dead game of
Thrones stuff happening so be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be an awesome weekend just thinking
about Clara
so you'd be really happy that she's gone
some of you just be really happy to see
whoever's coming next who the next
campaign is gonna be white guys wait for
everything to post in case you haven't
seen it I just posted a Jessica Jones
episode video you can click here to
watch that and you can click here to
watch the latest Flash arrow crossover
trail that I just posted thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five and I'll see you guys tonight